sometimes you feel like you're doing
something because you have to and you
don't really want to but that have to is
wrapped up in self-worth or numbers or
sales or getting promoted or um having
the opposite sex be attracted to you or
you're doing something by choice because
like you're making a deliberate choice
in the moment to do something because
it's what you actually want to do and i
think that the more that we can do the
latter the happier healthier and more
sustainable our performance will be
brought still a bug welcome the show
hey chris it's a pleasure to be here how
do you describe what you do for work
i coach and i write i wear those two
hats so in my coaching practice i work
with executives entrepreneurs and a
handful of physicians
and i help them on their performance and
well-being and in my writing i am very
interested in exploring those same
topics so what makes for sustainable
performance what does it actually mean
to be well how can you marry performance
and well-being and i explore that in my
books and in my magazine work
what are
like among the high performers that you
work with what are some of the most
common errors that you see people making
yeah i think that there's a lot of
selection bias in my own coaching
practice because the people that come to
me for coaching have almost
like unanimously read my work
so i'm fortunate that people come to me
wanting to um
to find a little bit more fulfillment in
what they're doing
and i think it's a lot of people that go
into whatever it is that they do off the
bat for all the right reasons
but then it can get noisy later on in
your career and it's hard to find that
signal
and um i think a lot of people come to
me
very successful by conventional
standards
but perhaps wanting to
um feel more internally successful if
that makes sense
yeah it's something that i think all of
us play with this
desire for success but also the
happiness to be where we are and to sort
of just have our feet underneath you i
read a this cal newport article about
how you downsized your life can you
explain how you decide what you
let in and out of your daily routine now
so that kale article um focused on a
couple years back uh my partner caitlin
and i and our young son theo decided
that we wanted to move out of
a high cost of living urban area we were
in the bay area where it's very
expensive to live
to go to a place that afforded us
a little bit more autonomy
so we felt that we wouldn't have to
necessarily work as hard as often
perhaps could start saying no to things
that we didn't want to do if we didn't
have to pay a gazillion dollars in rent
every month
so we moved to a small mountain town in
north carolina and that's definitely the
biggest thing that we've done to
simplify
um some of the other things that i try
to do to simplify my life i am very
structured in how i separate coaching in
my writing work so i only coach on
mondays and fridays
and then tuesday wednesday thursday i
have for writing in more creative
activities
um what i have found both in myself and
with a lot of people that i work uh that
i work with is that
oftentimes the switching between tasks
is the thing that actually drains you
not so much the task itself so in my own
life i found that if i had a coaching
client and i was in a writing groove i
would resent having to coach someone and
that is not what you want in a coach
it's not what i want in myself
and if i was
um
in a coaching group like just talking to
clients really being fully present
helping people the last thing i want to
do is have to go work on an article on
deadline
so um something that has been really
helpful is again really
compartmentalizing those two components
of my work
and
you're talking to me in the middle of a
book launch so it's an aberration i'd
say for the few weeks after a book comes
out but in the normal worlds of brad um
just really making sure that i
prioritize
uh physical practice so something that
i'm doing with my body where i am not
online i am not thinking about work uh
time outdoors with my dog and then in
the evening really trying to shut
everything down by 6 30 pretty
religiously
it's interesting to think about someone
who decides to
give up
the high expenses in order to have the
the more simple that life i think people
get stuck on that hamster wheel a little
bit and they just can't get off
what is it
about
how hard was it for you to let go of
that how hard is it to let go of the the
nice house and the good postcode with
the expensive cars and the nice
neighbors and stuff like that
yeah you know i feel like i didn't
really have to let go of that because i
still feel like if anything we have a
house that's much larger than we could
have afforded there um
so i think a lot of it was just like
letting go of this idea that you know
there's all this energy in a place and
therefore one should be in that place
the hardest thing about moving was
leaving behind some really close friends
and um i think that's hard regardless of
where you move but i didn't struggle i'm
not like a status seeking person so
for me like the allure of living in the
bay or living in new york city that was
never really a thing for me so i didn't
find it very hard if anything it was it
was just leaving those friends and it
became like the very rational thing to
do
what's the problem that you're trying to
solve with your new book
right now yes
yeah i think it's the perennial problem
of any new author or excuse me at least
any new book
is trying to get people to read it um
i am not only competing with a bunch of
other great books that people could be
reading but i'm competing with netflix
with hulu
with podcasts with true murder stories
um so in in a game where people have
limited attention and there are so many
various
um things preying on that attention or
buying for it uh the problem i'm trying
to solve is how do i make the case that
hey i want you to give me
you know 16 to 30 or pounds or euros
wherever you are and a couple weeks of
your time and what's the problem that
the book is trying to solve itself
the book is trying to solve the problem
that i mentioned that i see quite often
in my coaching clients and something
that i've clearly experienced myself
which is this getting so caught up
in what you're doing because you like
what you're doing
but having the inertia
of that caught up-ness in the book i
call it frantic activity frenetic energy
just completely unmoor you so it feels
like instead of having a solid
foundation instead of being where you
are you're constantly being pushed and
pulled around by all the activities in
your life
why do you think is that just inherent
is that inbuilt in humans is that a
malaise of the modern day is it a
combination
i think it's a combination for sure i
think that we always have a propensity
to focus on bright shiny objects and to
neglect like the fundamental
foundational principles
um
you look in sports it's much fancier to
work on you know your crossover dribble
and your three-point shot than it is the
fundamentals you look in weight training
no one likes to do stabilization
exercises everyone wants to squat or
bench press
um so i think that some of it is just
human nature that we're attracted to
things that are bright and shiny and
sexy and that's fine so long as those
things don't cannibalize time and energy
spent for our foundational or basic
principles
so this book is really a call to get
back to those basic principles and
argues that you can still strive and you
still get to the same place but the
texture of the striving
is a lot better and a lot more
fulfilling to use that sports analogy
again
you can you can train really hard for a
competition
and your chance of injury
goes way down
if you've built a solid foundation it's
not to say that you can't win without
the solid foundation but it's going to
be a lot more angst provoking whereas if
you do the work of building that solid
foundation when you really go for it
you've got a lot more robustness
anti-fragility and durability
and i'm trying to apply that kind of
thinking to one's whole life what does a
foundation look like in this context
yeah so a foundation is really being
able to practice a couple key qualities
that create this way of being in the
world which i call groundedness
and those qualities in brief are
acceptance presence patience
vulnerability and deep community um and
then i also incorporate this notion of
really inhabiting your body
um i think this is true if you are in
more of a traditional knowledge work
type role it's so easy to think of your
brain as this thing that is in your
skull if it's like a machine and that is
not what we are at all
what about the tension between
being happy and then striving to be
where you want to be i think a lot of
people
in the productivity world in the
biohacking world longevity space
fundamentally i believe that a lot of
their motivations comes from a fear of
insufficiency a desire for more that
when i get when i do when i achieve when
i am i will be xyz i will be happy
fulfilled have a partner feel enough
um so it is a motivating force that
sense of insufficiency can cause us to
be motivated to move forward because
we're fleeing from something that we
don't want is there a fear that by
getting rid of that fear you're now no
longer motivated to go and get something
so i think it depends on the person um i
think a very small minority of people
perform better from a place of
insecurity because they feel that
motivation really strongly i don't think
it makes them happier but perhaps they
perform better
most people
perform much better from a place of
freedom or love or true confidence
so
the way that i think about it is this if
you are on the start line of any
metaphorical race could be a marathon
but it could also be trying to be a ceo
of your company a best-selling author
top podcast on apple you name it
if you feel like you have to achieve
that goal to have self-worth
or you have to achieve that goal to um
have an identity that you're proud of
you are going to be pretty tight along
the way because there is a lot at stake
whereas if you are on that start line
and you already feel good enough
and you already feel loved you already
have self-love you already feel loved by
members of your community
i argue and the research supports this
that you have a much better chance
of really easing into like that flow
zone where you are having fun along the
way and as a result of that you're
performing better and it's significantly
more sustainable
um
you know i i do think that it's a huge
misconception and i'm glad that you
asked me about it that you
you have to
um like feel like you're not enough to
get better and i think a big paradox is
you have the best chance of getting
better when you're doing it from a place
of not um excuse me of already feeling
enough of not having that insecurity
what was some of the evidence of the
research that you looked at to do with
that
yeah it's um a lot of that comes down to
this notion of getting into a flow state
which i'm sure prior guests have spoken
about but in short it's when you're in
the zone
perception of time and space changes
you're really playing to win instead of
playing not to lose
and in order to play to win
you have to have a secure sense of self
and if that secure sense of self isn't
there then of course you play not to
lose because the stakes again are so
high um so it's a much more joyful fun
way to go about um to go about trying to
be your best
how does that relate how does a flow
state relate to holding on too tightly
and being too tense
yeah i think that if you're holding on
too tightly and being too tense by
definition you can't get into a flow
state so a flow state
is um
often characterized by a loss of ego
so you cease to exist right you are one
with your activity and this can be very
acute it can be you're playing chess
you're doing a math proof or flow states
can ebb and flow for years like you are
a researcher that is developing this um
this new technology or this new
medication this new vaccine and of
course you're gonna have some bad days
but you are on a hot streak in your
career let's say
and
again a huge quality of these states is
a loss of self you're not worried about
yourself because if you're worried about
yourself you can't become one with your
craft
and if you are insecure and if you're
tight you're worried about yourself
so in order to get into a flow state you
have to let go of the self
um this is what modern science shows
it's also key across all the ancient
wisdom traditions so
in tibetan buddhism
the in so many different
traditions of that practice
they conceptualize nirvana or
enlightenment is orgasm
and the reason that they do that is
because during orgasm you lose a sense
of self
you cease to exist
and
what the buddhists call nirvana or
enlightenment what the taoists call the
way
even with the greeks in the west called
urete or this sense of like really
fulfilling excellence
millennia ago today modern researchers
call flow the key to all of these things
is you can't be worried about yourself
naval has a quote
where he says something similar
where he talks about
if you care too much if you grip too
tightly at the task that you're doing
you inevitably end up not being very
good at it because there is a looseness
that's required yeah you gotta
for sure you have to relax and win um
and it's that's not my quote there's a
famous uh coach called bud winter and he
would say relax and win
um or it's like the paradox of trying
which is trying really really hard works
until it gets in your way
i like that i guess whenever you think
about an athlete that's got the yips
that's just completely off in their game
but the the cricketer that just can't
hit the strip anymore when he's bowling
the
the guy that's just missing every move
that's why it's not because they don't
have the embodied knowledge it's because
they've got too much cognitive
horsepower trying to wrangle it around
yep there's too much self associated and
you know the example i always come back
to
um is sex because it's something that
most adults experience
and if you're like really worried about
like how you're performing or what your
partner thinks of you
it's not it's not gonna feel good and
you're not gonna do well whereas if you
let go you get in the zone and in my
reporting i talk to mathematicians i
talk about you
know about math
i talk to athletes i talk to executives
and they all say the same thing
that when they can really let go
that is when they hit stride and again
what's fascinating is in my reporting i
found it's not just in the moment but it
can be for months or even years at a
time
i read a
study
shared by a guy called deegan rolfe who
if people aren't following him on
twitter everyone needs to go follow him
he's fascinating
and um
he
was talking about the reason that women
don't achieve orgasm during sex a lot of
the time and the most common reason that
was reported was
self um
remunerating said uh self sort of uh
internal monologues that people just
can't stop thinking ruminating self
ruminating remunerate imagine if you're
paying yourself for sex uh
self-ruminating and um this was the
reason and a lot of uh some women
believe that
physically they are not constructed in a
manner that allows them to achieve
orgasm in certain ways
and others are and what the research
seems to suggest is that
it's got far less to do with your
physiology and far more to do with your
psychology specifically during sex
yeah it makes that makes a lot of sense
and and to take it out of the bedroom
you can also think about anxiety and
depression which are both disorders
um that are very self-focused so anxiety
is all about what's going to go wrong
with me in the future and i need to
protect me or i need to protect the
things i care about into the future it's
a very like inward looking focus and
depression
is all about what's wrong with me in the
past or regrets or things that i can't
stop thinking about david foster wallace
has written so beautifully about how the
depressive person
is in some ways um a disorder of ego
because there's so much inward focus in
being trapped with your ego with
yourself is is a lousy way to be
and i think a lot of people
at a sub-clinical level are kind of
feeling exhausted all the time not
feeling so fulfilled because they're
constantly trapped in this state
and i also think that it's not any
individual's fault i think we have an
entire culture
that is set up to trap you in that state
i mean the whole consumer culture is you
don't feel good and then you buy this
thing and you feel better you don't feel
enough then you achieve this thing and
you feel better and if people actually
felt really good
um
then the whole thing would go
at least a lot of it bingo yeah that's
the problem of a meritocracy right
the more that i think because i love it
i love the fact that you can be anything
you want to be and that your hard work
gets you your rewards and stuff
and then on the flip side of it the more
that i think about it i'm like oh man
there are some negative side effects of
this there are some things where
if the people that win are worthy of
their successes then the people people
who lose
what does that make them and it's not a
the outcomes aren't very nice and then
talking about um
individualism you have a heroic
individualism that you talk about in the
book what's that
yeah so it's the it's the basic syndrome
that i classify
as
being in a never-ending game
of uh one upsmanship
against yourself and others so
constantly needing to beat yourself
constantly needing to be others
where
measurable
results are the main arbiter of success
so back to your point about the
meritocracy and the key point is the
finish line is an illusion
so you think that the goal post is 10
yards down the field you get there and
then you realize that it's actually 10
yards beyond that
we briefly touched on this in the
beginning of the conversation it's like
if then syndrome if i achieve this then
i'll be fulfilled if i achieve this then
i'll be confident around my neighbors if
i achieve this then i'll be worthy
um and what the research shows is that
that kind of thinking
just keeps you on the hamster wheel
so what's the alternative
the alternative is to develop a sense of
groundedness a sense of being where you
are being strong and confident where you
are
that does not eliminate ambition it does
not eliminate striving i am a huge i
wouldn't write books if i thought that
it did like writing a book is a big
ambition it's a striving pursuit
uh it just situates that striving
so that the texture of the journey
becomes more fulfilling and more
sustainable um
quick metaphor
two ways to reach the top of a mountain
right you've got one climber that is
constantly obsessive about the peak and
can't wait to take a selfie on the peak
can't wait to tell all their friends
that they're on the peak and if he
didn't reach the peak then he's a
failure so he's got to get to that peak
the other climber
he is very much focused on where he is
he's enjoying the journey he is
meticulously consistent about you know
executing the right pitches at the right
times and in the evening he's chilling
out he's enjoying the side from the top
excuse me he's enjoying the view from
the side of the mountain both of those
climbers
can reach the top of the mountain
but i argue that the one that's enjoying
the way that's grounded where they are
they're going to come back and do it
again and again whereas the other guy
even if he reaches the top of the
mountain he's going to be so exhausted
from the anxiety he's going to be like i
don't really want to do this um the
other way to think about it is you're
doing something from a place of choice
or from a place of compulsion
and i think
probably all listeners have experienced
this i certainly have sometimes you feel
like you're doing something because you
have to and you don't really want to but
that have to is wrapped up in self-worth
or numbers or sales or getting promoted
or
having the opposite sex be attracted to
you
or you're doing something by choice
because like you're making a deliberate
choice in the moment to do something
because it's what you actually want to
do and i think that the more that we can
do the latter
the happier healthier and more
sustainable our performance will be all
right so the principles acceptance what
are we accepting
we're accepting our situation as it is
it's as simple and as hard as that we're
not deluding ourselves um we're not
pushing back against something that we
don't like we are taking very clear
stock of where we are what's happening
internally and externally
and really this is a practice to do
every single day because your
situation's always changing
it seems like a lot of therapies use
that as the fundamentals like try and
get rational about exactly where you're
at
yeah try to get rational um or if you
can't get rational because depression or
anxiety is preventing you from except
that right now you can't get rational
uh
i think that the the goal of acceptance
and how do you actually practice this in
real life really comes down to creating
some space
between
a situation be it internal a thought or
a feeling or external something
happening in the world in a deeper sense
of yourself
so that you can see that situation
clearly what so often happens is we fuse
with our situations and when you're
fused with something you can't see it
but if you can create some distance
between you and it
then
you have the ability to do something
wise and discerning and thoughtful about
what's happening
what is a a way that you would create
that space
yeah so there's um
there's three ways that i i like to kind
of introduce um to people that are new
to this concept
um the first way
is some sort of meditation practice
and i'll be brief on it because the
wisdom podcast i'm sure listeners know
but
just in case you're new or you don't
know a lot of people come into
meditation and think the point is to
like
chill out and calm down
and
maybe you'll get that occasionally
that's a nice byproduct but for most new
meditators
you're basically just realizing what a
[ __ ] your mind body system is all
the time because thoughts feelings
doubts what am i gonna have for dinner i
haven't talked to my brother i need to
call him my you know my colleague hates
me all that stuff comes up and the whole
practice is to go back to your breath
now why because what you're doing by
going back to your breath is you're
centering yourself in a way that's
separate from those thoughts or feelings
and you do this often enough and you can
start to see
thoughts and feelings as being separate
from you and when you see them you can
choose do i want to engage in this or do
i just want to let it go
two other ways to do it
one is to pretend that a really close
friend is in the same situation as you
and then give advice to that friend
we are much much much better at giving
advice to friends than we are ourselves
and that's because there's some distance
and then the third way to create that
space is to imagine an older wiser
version of yourself
looking back on you right now what would
that older wiser version tell you to do
and all three of these strategies fall
under what researchers call
self-distancing
so
creating some space between i call it
like a cute self or the self that's
experiencing something in longer term or
deeper self which is aware of what acute
self is experiencing
yeah corey allen calls it the
mindfulness gap that beat you in between
stimulus and response and yeah i mean if
that's the only thing
that i develop from meditation if the
only thing that i ever get is the fact
that there's a little bit of a
mindfulness gap like a half
second break sometimes when a thing
happens and i notice it arise inside of
me and i have a little bit of time
to consider how i want to respond to it
i'm going to consider it a win i think
that was a time well spent
yeah and i think the other thing that is
um
is part and parcel of acceptance that i
would i would
loop together or merge together with
what you just said is also some
self-compassion
so
acceptance only works if you can have
some self-compassion because otherwise
um you're just gonna constantly be
beating yourself up for shitty
situations
and we know that beating yourself up
does nothing to actually help you
mobilize and take productive action
um so i think in addition to creating
that space
you realize that like yeesh like my
brain is a crazy machine and you can
start to be kinder to yourself you can
start to laugh at yourself more often
there's a quote attributed to a woman
that
[Applause]
was was dying of cancer and talking
about her meditation practice and she
said that every itch not scratched was a
lesson in self-compassion
and i just think it's so beautiful
because i think what that means is that
every time you have an itch
and you don't scratch it but you watch
it you get curious about it you watch it
ebb and flow and crest and then start to
recede
you have to be kind here like it is hard
there are so many itches that we just
want to scratch
and if you can realize that then you
kind of have to start to intrinsically
be kinder to yourself um and i think
that's a big part of acceptance
how can people pattern interrupt if
they've got a bad monologue if there's
someone who has quite a negative
self-talk what are some of the ways that
people can try to break that
so you know i don't love the word hack
because i think that most things require
consistency in practice but if there is
one quote-unquote hack
um it would be to replace the word
should
with want or wish
so
language shapes so much of our reality
is a species it's in large what
separates us from other species
and the word should is so judgment-laden
so as i write in the book don't shut all
over yourself i should do this i should
do that i shouldn't have done this
replace that with want or wish
i want to do this and if you don't want
to do it then you should then you
shouldn't don't
um
or
i wish i would have exercised today i
wish i would have been kinder to my
spouse today
um
that just has such a transformative
effect even after like a week or two and
then the other thing that i would say
is
be really mindful of judging yourself
for judging yourself
so anytime i i have someone that gets um
gets going on this notion of trying to
be a little bit kinder and break out of
the pattern of judgment
well what happens is you realize how
often you judge yourself
and then as i said you judge yourself
for judging yourself and then you judge
yourself for judging yourself for
judging yourself this is all normal in
part of the path
all that you need to do is pay really
close attention and eventually you just
start to laugh at yourself and that to
me is the beginning of self-compassion i
read this taylor pearson blog quote a
while ago and he was talking about this
story from when he was in singapore
20 years ago and he's some young kid
who's just left college and he was going
traveling
and he had to make a decision between
whether he wanted to work on his website
or whether he wanted to go out for beers
with his friends on the evening time
and he wrote down um what sort of
[ __ ] person decides to have a
three-hour debate with themselves about
whether or not they should go out for
beers with their friends and it was the
first time that i'd ever heard
anybody
openly express shame at their own
self-judgment you know the judging about
judging about judging and
you're right you can really make a a
hell of heaven if you're not careful
doing that like ostensibly everything
can be going right but your judgment
about the situation can be judged by you
and you can then wreck everything
i was having a perfectly fine time and
that i guess leads us on to the second
principle which is presence
yeah one more thing on the judgment
because i think it's a really nice
metaphor um
so in buddhism they talk about the
second arrow
and
it's this notion that the first arrow
is a thought feeling event circumstance
you cannot control the first arrow but
the second arrow which is your self-talk
or your judgment or your repression or
your denial or your magical thinking
that you can control
in the buddha taught that it's the
second arrow that hurts worse than the
first arrow
and the second arrow is so often
judgment and then as you said it becomes
the third arrow the fourth arrow the
fifth arrow
so acceptance isn't passive resignation
it's being able to say like oh this
thing happened or i had this thought
okay i see it
what should i do about it that's it
and the more quickly you get to that
the better you'll be and the better
you'll feel
um all right so yeah just second arrows
because that's been helpful for me often
when i catch myself judging or
repressing or pushing away or not
wanting to confront and then getting mad
that i'm doing those things um i just
tell myself like you're firing more
arrows and that helps snap me back to
the present moment i like that yeah um
james altucher has a similar one he
calls not useful so whenever he has a
thought that arises in his mind he just
labels it as not useful he's like look
if this thought isn't useful to me what
the [ __ ] am i doing like why am i even
considering this it's complete waste of
time it's not useful uh yeah so presence
so presence uh
the simplest description of it that i
can offer is being where you are
both physically and psychologically
and you know a common theme in my work
and a common theme in this book is that
simple is not easy
what are
well i guess that if you're accepting
first if you're not if you're not able
to accept
you're going to be in your own head so
much the judgment's going to be there
that's going to drag you out of the
presence
100 so that is the first that's why it's
the first principle and it's the doorway
to presence um
what are some of the practices that you
use for presence
so
i
am
well [ __ ] i don't have to tell you i've
been using metaphors all along i was
gonna say i am a big fan of metaphors so
here's another metaphor
peanut m m's and brown rice you've got a
bowl of peanut m ms in front of you and
a bowl of brown rice in front of you
what are you going to pick up and eat
if you're a normal human the peanut m ms
they taste so much better they taste
better for the first bite for the fifth
bite for the first 10 minutes
after an hour of eating peanut m ms you
might start to feel a little sick
after a day or a week or a month or a
year you feel like [ __ ]
whereas the brown rice first few bites
they're not as gratified but if you make
brown rice a staple of your diet
and brown rice is arbitrary any whole
nourishing food you actually feel really
really good
in presence in today's world is like
brown rice there are so many sources of
novelty and distraction and just dumb
stimulus bombarding us from all angles
all the time those are the peanut m ms
and they taste really good it's easier
to check your comments on youtube or to
refresh twitter or even to go to a new
site to get some jolt of excitement than
it is to
focus on writing the story that you
wanted to write or
build the financial model that you've
been putting off or have a very intimate
conversation with a close friend or
romantic partner
yet those things
they are the things that give meaning to
our life and over the long haul make us
feel good
so what's the practice the same exact
thing i'd say to someone that's
struggling with eating too much junk
food get the junk food out of your house
so to the extent that you can
find those sources of novelty and
stimulus that are impeding on your
ability to be present and cut them out
take the apps off your phone
i know people that have a separate cheap
computer that they just use for big work
projects and it has no internet on it so
like that distraction's not there
um
boundaries are so important right
because there are actually physical
things that you can do
again take the internet off your
computer take the apps off your phone
but also psychological so
xpm rolls around
i am done with this and now i'm shifting
to that
and that can be family time that can be
physical practice that can be reading
but if you are in a candy store
trying to eat brown rice it is very hard
so the first practice that i'd say is
just get out of the candy store
that works really well for external
distractions
internal distractions are a little bit
harder to control you can't control your
thoughts or feelings
so there it's very similar to acceptance
it comes back to this ability to be
mindful
to be able to see thoughts and feelings
without immediately jumping into them
and engaging on them
and then the final thing is
to pay close attention to the supply
side to speak in economic terms
so demand side is what's demanding your
attention supply side is what are you
doing
and
if you are choosing really meaningful
cool endeavors that interest you that
you're curious about in your life it
should be easier to pay attention
so if you're really struggling to pay
attention yeah maybe it's all the
distractions maybe it's that you're
stuck in your head but it could also be
that you're not spending your time on
things that you truly value
we saw this in cal's new yorker
piece right he was talking about was it
called the great redundancy or the great
leaving or the great resignation that
was it yeah
and people knowledge workers leaving
their jobs in droves uh presumably
because they've had a little bit of a
break and they go actually
this this this job's [ __ ]
i don't i don't want to do this anymore
but you needed that space right you
needed the
phone locked outside of the room
equivalent which was you being
quarantined at home away from your job
for a while
yeah getting out of the candy store
exactly
um
this gets like way off the the topic of
conversation today but this is why i'm
becoming increasingly a big fan of
universal basic income
because um i think that
if technology and innovation continue to
accelerate
um
a lot of jobs we just won't have to do
and i think the notion of having
somebody do work that is kind of
[ __ ] just so that they're working
and kept busy
is like a complete misunderstanding of
how incentives work and i'd rather
people that own the capital
you know get gazillions of dollars and
are taxed and then everyone gets 60k or
whatever it is and those people can go
make music or make art or start podcasts
and do all these things that are more
meaningful and better for them and
arguably in some cases better for the
world
do you think that everyone has the
ability to find a passion or a pursuit
that they genuinely feel resonates with
them that's a lot of hard work what
we're talking about at the moment the
people that
mostly were speaking to are the ones who
have degrees of freedom to choose the
direction that they're going in that in
their life
but
if you were to look back ancestrally
someone getting a a craft or a trade of
some kind you know being a wheel worker
or a stone mason or a farmer these are
the sort of jobs that people would
typically have had now they give you a
sense of meaning and belonging and
purpose but they're also not the thing
that you would have chosen so my only
real concern or the the major concern i
would say that i have with ubi
would be
a lot of people are bestowed their sense
of identity and well-being within the
world from their job
even if it's not necessarily the first
thing that they would have chosen i
wonder how many
existential crises we're going to see if
you take that option away from people
oh for sure i think we'll see plenty and
like it's not like you know a a 100 win
zero percent loss i think it's a mixed
bag
um
i think that those examples that you're
giving i think they have one very
different thing with so much of the work
world today
and you alluded to it but those jobs
were meaningful they weren't [ __ ]
if you're a stone mason you get to build
a freaking house
if you are a vp of
product in the left wing on the right
side of the company half the time you
don't know what the [ __ ] you do
um and you see this there are entire
layers of knowledge work organizations
where
the whole job is to go to meetings and
to have multiple minions report to you
so you can feel powerful
and it's utterly unfulfilling
and i think that it is like it is nuts
i'm so glad you mentioned a stonemason
because the other day i don't even know
how i got in this topic i started
googling like the median income for a
stonemason
and saw it was like 35 000.
and that is
i don't know a third of the starting
income for most knowledge workers yet
stonemasons they're freaking building
houses
so i do think that like there's a
disconnect between real value and fake
value now
who am i to say that right i write books
like are books really valuable they're
certainly not houses but
i can tell myself the story that it's a
lot more valuable than trying to like
win the game at some excel spreadsheet
i agree i know that your buddies with
cal newport and one of the big things
that you take from his work is the
cranking widgets example the fact that
you can see the work that is done and
the problem that we have with knowledge
work is it's this big
[ __ ] off amorphous blob right it's just
this ephemeral cloudy bastard that's
just floating around and no one actually
knows if i've done it no one knows what
dun even looks like you can't even
define what done is it is this constant
conveyor belt of just like vanilla paste
that's constantly being pumped into your
computer and when you're done it's when
the end of the day is there and
sometimes it's not even then so yeah
yeah can i can i continue down this this
like little road for a little yeah yeah
yeah keep walking
so
i have uh i have this mentor named mike
and
for the last year mike's answer to most
questions that i had
was keep dead lifting
and the questions had nothing to do with
fitness it was like you know
next book deal should i do this should i
do that should should i focus on growing
a podcast like just keep dead lifting
i'd be worried about the political
situation in this country mike would
just be like keep dead lifting
and
it occurred to me
that that's the wisest advice he could
have given me because what he's saying
is do something real in the world
and that grounds you that centers you
that keeps you here
and i wrote a piece for our newsletter
and there's a little bit of this worked
into the book that i think particularly
so much of a problem
with a lot of people in power that have
gone totally off the reservation as of
late and and i do think just
statistically they happen to be men
and that's probably not an accident
andrew cuomo donald trump um
to an extent jeff bezos richard branson
they've done great things but they're
also trying to go to space and in like
bill gates is another example he built
great things but like now maybe he's
like harassing workers
i wonder i can't help but wonder if what
happens is you get to a point where
you're so powerful
that if you don't do real things in the
world you never fail
because people are always saying yes to
you people are telling you how great you
are you can throw money at any problem
but if you deadlift
every once in a while you're going to
miss the lift it's going to be really
hard it doesn't have there's nothing
special about dead lifting run try to
garden and like see your flowers die
don't hire a gardener do it yourself mow
your lawn
and i think that like a lot of our
problems come down to people not doing
real things in the world i think the
total cluster [ __ ] quagmire that we see
on social media about politics
some of our politicians are batshit
crazy but a lot of people spend their
days in this argument instead of doing
real stuff in the world
um
so i especially of knowledge workers
um
so yeah i think it's like it's a really
important point to harp on and i'm glad
that we've hit on it is just the value
of protecting some time or space
to do something that is real where you
will succeed or fail
because it has a way of working on you
that keeps you humble
yeah what's the what should be the the
things the elements that people are
looking out for there is it
to try and have something that manifests
physically
um is it
something that you're likely to fail at
have you got any prescription around
that
yeah so here i'm going to quote the
philosopher matt crawford
and what he says is you should try to do
things where you don't have to offer
half hour long chattering vindications
of what it is you do
so if someone asks you what do you do at
your job and you're the vp of this that
or the other it might take you 20
minutes to explain
if someone asks you
what'd you do in the gym you could say i
either lifted the bar went up and i
locked out or it didn't the tree grew or
it didn't the lawn is mowed or it's not
um the lights turn on or they don't the
motorcycle engine's running or it's not
so i think that's the ultimate barometer
where you can say i either did it or i
didn't and failing is every bit as
important as succeeding because
otherwise you get in this world where
everything can kind of be
massaged with words and talked into
success or nothing's ever your fault or
everything's always your fault
where
some things like it hits you in the face
you don't get a lot of room for
interpretation man i've been on this
flex for a while thinking about the
beauty of sport and why it's so perfect
and sports people don't understand
the blissful situation that they're in
with this that
the objective metrics of success the
parameters for success and failure are
so obvious and tightly bound and and
they're there in front of you you know
what you were hitting in training you
know your percentages that you were
working up you know what you should be
expecting on the competition floor you
know how the last team played sons you
just know you know whether or not you've
succeeded or failed and we don't have
that in pretty much any other area of
life even if you were to think about
other physical manifestations of things
like music or art like who's to say that
you played that piece of music
objectively better or worse than last
week or objectively better or worse than
that person that was also going for the
job it's so subjective like
everything is bodybuilding except for a
few sports that aren't bodybuilding
that's it because it's all just [ __ ]
subjective and this yeah
causes everybody to not prepare
as
efficiently as they could do or should
do for the for their chosen pursuit
because who's to say that the fact that
you only slept for six hours last night
is the reason that that podcast is not
quite as good as it could have been
drawing the line
from preparation to performance is so
messy and it's so complicated that we
the degrees of freedom just give us a
pass always they always give us a pass
and i kind of lambasted myself about
this saying like look you say that you
want to be really really good at this
thing
but you're not turning up the way that
an athlete would do athletes cover every
single base nutrition mindset game tape
drills they're working on their
individual elements they're working on
their team performance their social
networks that way
everything that they do is geared
towards maximizing their performance and
because you think that you can get away
with not doing that
you don't bother
and yeah that's why athletes it's
a hell of a drug man like it's such a
perfect world to exist in even if it's
only for a while
yeah i'm so glad that you're bringing
this up um you know it's funny because
a huge part of this this groundedness is
being where you are and not worrying too
much about external validation
and yeah i'll tell you the external
validation that i'm here for
yesterday morning i woke up and my inbox
had five emails from nba gms in front
office people asking if they could have
books for their teams
and
it started off there's a guy named brent
berry he's the vp of basketball
operations for the san antonio spurs and
he read the book and he is just like oh
my gosh like
like this is what we need this is what
the spurs need like this is what we
achieve to do this is what we strive to
do to care about results but to be
present where we are
and um for me as a writer
and part of it is i'm a sports fan but
knowing that people
who actually what let me step back what
made me feel so good to see these these
emails come in is sure like maybe it'll
help sell books blah blah blah but these
people have skin in the game and they're
in the arena
and there is nothing better than when
you're wrestling with ideas and you're
making an argument and people that have
full skin in the game are like oh yeah
like this is the path
and i think that there's a reason that
the book resonates with with those sorts
of people is because the book isn't like
full of hacks or quick fixes like
everything is simple not easy and man
going back to your analogy of sports or
weightlifting or being on the pitch in
soccer like there's nothing that complex
about these games the rules are
straightforward everybody knows them
you literally if you hack you get
penalized because hacking is cheating
it's doping
so it's bounded and you have to show up
in in in simple not easy simple not easy
simple not easy day in and day out
um and of course those people are
fulfilled and happy
dude this is why i've got a buddy
mike cashew couple of time times
crossfit games champion and now he's
just bought a ranch actually um
three units down from ryan's ranch in
austin
we were talking about going out to see
him at some point and
i was saying dude man like if you need
someone to come and help with fences
or or
hoe a
trench somewhere or whatever d weed
stuff i am
so all over that and i looked
back at that conversation a couple of
hours afterwards i was like hang on a
second
that's what would be classed as the most
menial
low entry job in the world
and you are going out of your way to try
and offer your time to do that for free
like some sort of mindfulness exercise
but why is that it's because i want to
manifest something in the real world i
want bounded metrics of success and
failure uh yeah i genuinely think that
we're going to see more and more people
come upon this realization and that that
that helps around you like because again
like you're you're actually in the real
world
yeah like by definition there's gravity
there like you're not in your head you
are working in that case you're
literally working on the ground um
i i'm so excited to see you're excited
it's getting me excited because i love
this topic
i um
part of the biggest benefit of moving to
the smaller mountain town in north
carolina is now i've got like some
a lawn and some land i'm not in a
high-rise apartment building and i
mentioned deadlift so i deadlift i'm a
pretty big guy i'm in i'm into strength
training
but i've also gotten super into
gardening for the same reason like i
love planting flowers and watering them
and like trying to pay attention to like
the weather outside and the angle of the
sun what good kids have you planted
oh man well it's funny because this is
all brand new so i planted a sugar maple
which is doing really well but
i just go to the garden store i got in
this kick i'm going there like every
weekend and i don't know the next you
know next to nothing about flowers and i
got all these flowers and they're so
freaking fragile
and i have no idea why they're dying so
i walk down the street i ask our
neighbor lynn who's like a master
gardener i'm like what am i doing wrong
she's like you bought pansies
so you know like growing up right but
you know people at least in the states
people call you a pansy like if you're
soft
yeah they're the most fragile flowers i
didn't know that
um
so so i'm learning um
but um marigolds do great but anyways
like the point is that it it look much
like you had that aha moment it's like
why am i so into this especially around
the time i'm launching a book
because launching a book
is publicity and trying to get a list
and asking people to tweet about it it's
all this stuff that has like is not real
it exists in fiber optic cables on
computers
planting in the ground is as real as you
can get
bounded versus unbounded man you should
get out i should mail you a cutting of
my clematis montana which is
fantastic it's just it's just flowered
it's just about to flower again um it's
not my it's my mum my mom comes around
and does all manner of nice things to
the garden and then i just get to go and
enjoy it all right so the next uh
principle patience
yeah so patience um is giving things the
time and space to unfold
uh and
not always feeling the need to make
things happen
but sometimes also letting things happen
is that short term and long term is
there a different mindset that you need
for within the moment versus
with plans and goals and projects over
periods of time
yes there is and i think that the
letting thing happen versus making
things happen is definitely um a
long-term view
and just taking that long-term view
right realizing
that any kind of sustainable performance
requires patience because otherwise the
temptation to engage in heroic efforts
where you crush yourself
um it's really strong because those feel
really good they feel heroic in the
moment but they're not sustainable so
you see a lot of people do great things
for a very short period of time and then
burn out or worse end up depressed
and
i argue that a better approach
is to be like consistently good enough
over a long ass period of time
and that's how you get sustainably great
um you see this again going back to
sports because it's so bounded you see
this in athletics all the time like you
always
always always want to stop one rep short
so if you're training intervals for
running
if you could do eight eight eight by
four hundred stop at seven because the
eighth one's the one where you're going
to box yourself or injure yourself if
you're squatting and you could do four
sets of six do four sets of five and
like the way that you build capacity
is by making yourself challenged but not
boxing yourself because if you box
yourself
then it's much harder to come back the
next day
and sports people have figured this out
but in the corporate world or in the
more creative intellectual world um this
has not yet been figured out and people
push themselves all the way to fatigue
all the time and then they wonder why
they burn out when if they would show
the discipline in the restraint like an
athlete to stop one rep short they'd
have a much easier time being
sustainable well you don't know where
the boundary is as a knowledge worker
you don't know and you can kid yourself
into thinking i can do more i've got
more in the tank i've seen
cal newport's book i can get more out of
my work day if i can just down regulate
my sleep or regulate my deep work
session i'll be able to get it done
again
there's just not
visceral feedback
in the same way as there is in the gym
like you know if you're an rpe 9.5 like
you know what that feels like
but i would argue that you don't when
you start
you have to pay attention like learning
rpe is a skill yeah is it newbie
rpe 6 and rpe 10 can feel a lot of love
right
they can and
and it's a skill to pay attention to and
in the book i argue that the same thing
is true for knowledge workers that if
you pay really close attention to how
you're feeling
in the outcome what you get out of it
then you can start to dial it in what so
for me when i'm writing yeah when i'm
writing
if i start to hunch over at the computer
and if my eyebrows kind of start
scrunching up
and if um
my my wife might like say something and
like i have a very like impatient
response
that i'm i'm pushing too far
now it's not to say listen sometimes you
want to go to the well right you're at
the powerlifting meet you're on
ascending yeah yeah exactly love it but
um that should be the exception not the
norm so for me those cues are like a
physical tightness
um and as a writer it's it's not that
hard to know because i know when i'm
having to work really hard to get
sentences out versus when they're just
kind of happening
and if i pay attention this over time
which i have i realize that it's
generally at about the hour and 45
minute mark
that i'm tempted to go check twitter 19
times during a sentence um i'm doing the
scrunching thing and that's when i'd be
better off just stopping doing something
else coming back to it later in the day
coming back to it tomorrow um
same thing with meetings in a workplace
i've been talking about this in the
context of the more traditional
workplace um with various organizations
and
most people when you ask them to pay
attention to like the right number of
meetings
they don't say zero
like they're they're honest about it but
generally they might say three or four
in a day so why are you scheduling five
or six
um so i i love your analogy of being
easier in the gym but i think it's only
easier in the gym because you're forced
when you have a bar over your chest to
pay attention and if we pay his close
enough attention in other pursuits we
get to know ourselves pretty well
yeah i thought for a long time
when i was in my 20s working so i run
club nights i have done for a very long
time it
hectic sleep schedule and heavy work and
a lot of um anxiety around performance
because it's such a fickle industry that
moves faster than anything else
and i kept it when you say club nights
is that like nightclubs correct yes um
so rather than owning the nightclub
itself we go in and operate individual
events in there um you're kind of like
uh kind of like in a polyamorous
relationship with a bunch of different
uh venues and then you go and drop you
thursday here and friday here and so on
and so forth yeah yeah got it so we're
awake till three in the morning and
we're designing the brands and we're
speaking to the networkers and we're
getting people in and we're booking djs
and so on and so forth but constantly
you know like for 15 years we've done
this and um
i used to have this period where
i would just after freshers week which
is what we're in right now
just after the period where everybody
arrives in the city and you you make
your stamp as a company and your events
you want to set the tone with the kids
that are going to be there for the next
three years you want to own that
thursday you want to have the the cheap
student night on a thursday or the
pretty girl bougie night on a friday
whatever you want to just own that
and then every start of october i'd be
in bed for three days in a row and i
wouldn't know why and i'd always blame
it on being psychologically too fragile
or i hadn't done the work or i should be
stronger than this so we've got the
guilt and the judgment about judgment in
there and sort of that self shame
but what i realized after a while was i
was like that's a miniature breakdown
like that's just a little breakdown that
you've had there you've worked hard to
the point and you've stressed yourself
and you've wound yourself up so tight
that you've had a little miniature
breakdown and it's actually quite
functional because your
system is telling you
you don't push too much
you need to take it's a mental
equivalent of getting injured in the gym
yep or or overreaching um or being on
the bounds of over training and just
needing a little bit more space to
recover
yeah and that's okay like i said it's my
goal is just to help people bring
awareness to this like there's nothing
wrong with doing that the problem is if
you're trying to do that all the time
the way that you mentioned it it's kind
of like you've got your big marathon
once a year and after you run the
marathon you need to take a week or two
off that's fine if you're in a situation
where every day is a marathon it's not
sustainable yeah so i suppose that
there's patience in that as well that i
don't need to try and pr every single
day
but also i can have patients waiting for
the cup final or the the world's
championship to come around and i can
send it then
100
all right vulnerability
yeah so vulnerability is being real with
yourself and others
as a way to build trust with yourself
and others
elaborate on that for me
the poet raynor maria rilch has this
beautiful line in one of his poems
where he says
wherever i am folded there i am a lie
i want to unfold i want to unfold
wherever i am folded there i am a lie
and what that means to me
is that if there are parts of us that we
fold up over
that we try to hide that we don't expose
we're lying to ourselves and
intellectually you can lie to yourself
but your subconscious mind it's going to
know that there is an insecurity there
and if you don't explore those
insecurities you can never trust all of
yourself
because you don't know all of yourself
so
at first vulnerability is really about
knowing
all of yourself being willing to go to
those places that you normally fold over
there's an allegory in greek mythology
about the god pan who lived just outside
of the village boundary
and oftentimes villagers would get lost
and they'd stumble into the forest and
then they would see pan
and pan was so terrifying
that they would freeze to death trying
to run away they would be paralyzed by
fear and die trying to escape pan when
they stumbled on him
every once in a while some villagers
would
go intentionally to visit pan
and when they went to visit him
intentionally pam bestowed upon them
timeless wisdom
to me that's what vulnerability is if we
try to run away if we try to ignore and
hide our vulnerabilities eventually
they're going to come up from the
surface and completely uproot us
if we actively go seek them
sometimes often with the help of
community members spiritual leaders
therapists psychiatrists
if we can go see our vulnerabilities and
face them they often have so much to
teach us
and paradoxically we grow much stronger
because we know all of ourselves
there's a story about king arthur and
his knights of the round table
and the way that they went into the
forest
at the end of which was supposed to be
the dragon and then the treasure
each of them had to enter the forest at
the point which looked darkest to him
that was how they chose it they chose
the point of maximum fear for each of
them individually and for each of them
it was different
but within that there was a dragon which
was the thing that they needed to face
and then beyond that was gold which was
a treasure that they wanted to get
what's a practice for people
vulnerability
yeah so uh
the first thing is just to
face those vulnerabilities and and i
think that often it is helpful to do
this with trusted friends or with a
professional with a therapist
but not just to face your
vulnerabilities but to ask yourself
what's on the other side of that fear
because those are your core values
so if you fear death
on the other side of death is life
so that tells you you better show up and
live your life
if you feel be if you fear being alone
and the other side of being alone is
connection so live your life in a way
that maximizes connection
if you fear emptiness on the other side
of emptiness is fulfillment and love
so go pursue love
so i think these vulnerabilities are are
are really really helpful
because they also help show us what
matters most to us and then we can
pursue those things
we can also connect to other people
because so many of the vulnerabilities a
lot of people experience are very common
they're part of the human condition it's
those ones i just mentioned it's
generally some sort of fear of aging
illness or death some sort of fear of
not being known or loneliness and some
sort of fear of emptiness
and
when
you can see those things in yourself you
can see them in others
and when others can see them in you
that's how you bond and it's often these
bonds
that overcome those vulnerabilities
so it is going through the dark part of
the forest to come out stronger and more
connected to other people
brene brown has done a lot of work on
this
her books are great i think that
what has happened
is that
over the last 10 years
in large part because of renee brown
even amongst dudes definitely amongst
women vulnerability became this thing to
aspire towards which is great
but the pendulum has swung so far
performance now you see a lot of ability
bingo performance vulnerability where
it's so easy to spot but it's people
posting on social media because they
want someone to like them and
you know in what i write in the book is
the litmus test is real vulnerability
should feel hard
if it doesn't feel uncomfortable it's
probably performative
that's a nice yardstick to use i guess
vulnerability leads into community as
well that vulnerability is assisted and
aided and stress tested and comforted by
having people around you that support
you
yep and invulnerability creates
community so we think that you need to
really know someone well and trust them
in order to be vulnerable with them
but research shows it's actually the
opposite that's true so by being
vulnerable with someone that's how you
build trust
a study that i write about in the book
was out of the university of manningham
in germany
and they had individuals sit down for a
conversation and they instructed one
person to be extremely vulnerable not
performative talk about experience with
depression anxiety bipolar divorce
loss of children loss of parents
feelings of loneliness
and after the conversation they had each
party give feedback and the person that
was doing the sharing vulnerably they
said that they felt weak they were
ashamed
the person on the receiving end
said that they had so much respect and
admiration for the person that was doing
the sharing and they thought that that
person was strong
so back to what's performative versus
what's not it should feel uncomfortable
when you're doing it yet that is what
helps people come to know you and
respect you and trust you and admire you
um
the other thing on community
is that as you were alluding to like
being a human is freaking hard trying to
figure this stuff out is hard
we're all going to go through periods of
meaninglessness and emptiness we're also
going to go through periods where
everything's clicking and our egos are
huge
and without a community
you like reach escape velocity when
things are going well and you become
donald trump or when things aren't going
well you like you get buried and
community is like it's gravity
and it's also a safety net
um
in the pali canon which is the the
oldest recorded buddhist text
um there's a line in there where the
buddha's loyal attendant ananda also the
name of my german shepherd um
he goes up to the buddha and he says
buddha buddha blessed one i've heard
that friendship
is 50 of the spiritual path is this true
and the buddha says no and on to no you
are mistaken it is not true
and ananda says blessed one blessed one
tell me what is true and the buddha
looks at ananda and says ananda
friendship community it's the whole of
the spiritual path it is 100 of the
spiritual path
and i just think that that is so
beautiful because people think about
any religion
as being all about the beliefs or the
connection that you have individually
with god or some higher power
and
it really is also about the community
that's here and now
it's an interesting one man the
the people that are high performers that
are
hard-working go-getters and individuals
i think
believing or having a lack of belief
that you can't do it on your own is is
quite worrisome you know you want to be
able to bear
that burden
all on your own you want to be able to
carry the weight on your on your own
shoulders i had this conversation with
jordan peterson and i asked him about um
the pain of losing friends as you grow
so you change and you kind of need to
let people from previous epochs of your
life
drop away and the youtube comments are
so interesting on the video there's so
much low-key resentment in there a lot
of messages and comments from people
saying things like
i've tried connecting with people and
it's just not right for me i'm gonna
make it on my own and it was
it's hundreds there's thousands of
comments on that video and there's
hundreds of them that are like that and
i think youtube skews towards a
particular
type of personality which is selecting
for that but you know even within the
youtube community it really shocked me
that so many people had been burned by
friendships or had struggled to make
them
and out of the other side of that this
was like that was their takeaway their
takeaway was i don't need anybody i can
go far and fast on my own i saw this
meme ryan mitchell from the order of man
podcast shared this meme the other day
and it's two sort of like chad drawings
of like chad men looking at each other
saying um
we were hurt by women and we didn't
reconcile our pain and then on the next
stage it says let's call ourselves alpha
men and it's like that's what's
happening a lot of the time that people
whether it's in the sort of mgtow
community or the meninism movement or
men's rights like a lot of that is
people that have been burned by a
relationship or a situation with a woman
and they now want to lay this blame at
the feet of all women and cast
themselves out of this situation look
that burn that injury was so bad
i i don't want to ever try and open that
wound up again and the same thing goes
for the way that people deal with
friendships but that's the paradox man
because it's that vulnerability that is
what's going to bring you into future
relationships
being able to cry and say i was burned
by this woman or by this friend and it
hurt so bad and i felt so lonely and so
worthless
guess what person down the street is
going to be like me too
because like we're all humans playing
the same game
so i think that rather than running away
from those things we need to open up
towards them
um
i also think and i i wonder if there's
some of this going on too
that
true relationships in community
are not means to an end they're ends in
themselves
so
if you're building relationships because
like
you know you want someone to help you
professionally and then they burn you
that is very different than having a
good relationship with your neighbors or
the barista in your coffee shop who
doesn't know that you have 10 books or
one book and doesn't know that you're a
ceo or you're working a minimum wage job
and those relationships i think are in
some ways easier because they are ends
in and of themselves
so i don't care how busy you are how
much you're trying to optimize how many
books you've written like deep community
for me
starts with like knowing your neighbors
and knowing that barista in the coffee
shop and having a relationship that has
nothing to do with the size of your dick
yeah and metaphorically how many books
you've written your ceo whatever yeah
yeah yeah because that's the stuff that
creates you
speaking about that man the lady across
the street so funny that you've got some
[ __ ] of a gardener for a
neighbor because so
and uh she's a beast and absolutely
she's got these sunflowers that are
seven feet high and this rose wall thing
yeah pretty pretty legit and um every
morning she'll be outside waving and you
think
it's such a it was never something that
i got taught while i was at uni you know
where he is a young sort of alpha chad
lad
banging and
slinging money around and trying to get
status and stuff
and then you realize you're like
actually that's pretty cool it's pretty
cool that julie across the street knows
my name and and that she can come over
and compliment me on my clematis montana
and stuff like that it's yeah it's weird
man i guess this is
this is part and parcel of growing up
and and finding something a bit more
timeless
yeah i think that's it um in realizing
that
you know it's good to have your podcast
and to want people to listen to it and
to want to get a bunch of downloads and
to land guests 10 times as big as me
that's all good and
having judy from down the street that's
also good and if you're only focused on
the former and not the latter you run
into problems
and you know maybe that's the message of
groundedness and the message of the book
is make sure that like you also know
judy down the street make sure that
you're still deadlifting once in a while
i like it brad stillberg ladies and
gentlemen people want to check out your
stuff where should they go
thanks for asking uh the book is
everywhere that books are sold so on the
internet it's on amazon barnes and noble
local book sellers
it should be in most places in the uk
and i think broadly in europe now if not
soon
and my website is just my name www
i love it man thanks very much for today
yeah thanks so much chris enjoyed this
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace